pushing themselves to their limits
whether on the road or on the running
track
but not all athletes rely just on hard
work to get to the top and Germany's
government is saying that needs to
change d Dortmund insh bot Logano sport
la athletes who dope will be covered by
this law and could receive jail terms of
up to three years staff and home perfect
currently if urine or blood tests show
traces of performance-enhancing drugs
athletes can only be banned from
competing this draft law wants to raise
the stakes Nadezhda [ __ ] by making
athletes in those pulling their strings
criminally liable we want to make clear
that doping is not just a sporting
matter but a criminal offense society as
a whole considers a criminal the new law
would complement and not replace the
powers of sport tribunals the tests for
finding out if an athlete is doped would
stay the same the anti-doping agency
nada says the load be a step in the
right direction the other thing is I
think it is very important to increase
the pressure on dopers and doping
systems and we can only do that together
using national laws and sports own rules
effectivity airplane can give it off but
first there'll be a lot more discussion
with various institutions the bill will
go to Parliament in the spring